a severe drought continues across the
west many are taking steps to conserve
so we are shedding some light on who is
using the most water in southern nevada
las vegas henderson and north las vegas
once again includes some big names with
some taking even more than they did back
in 2020 sasha loftis live in studio she
went through it all today joining us
with more on this issue sasha
bryan celebrities casino moguls and
major strip properties topped the water
use list last year with millions or even
billions of gallons taken many tell us
conservation is important as this
drought rage is on
it's a big concern right now yeah severe
drought is still crippling the west as
lake mead shoreline continues to shrink
and conservation efforts are top of mind
it would be nice if more of the places
could recycle the water this week eight
news now obtained lists of southern
nevada's top water users in 2021 the las
vegas valley water district has a
spanish trail property belonging to the
prince of brunei at the top with 13
million gallons used last year that's up
from 12 million the year before and
about 100 times more than the average
home the venetian came in first on the
commercial side with 481 million gallons
mandalay bay and caesar's palace were
also close behind in henderson ebay
founder pierre ahmedjar's property took
the top spot using about 9.3 million
gallons through last year lake las vegas
took a whopping 1.3 billion gallons
just over one percent of the water
allotted for our entire state
and aliante golf club leads in north las
vegas coming in just over 201 million
gallons we have other people who have to
you have to share the water with right
this as concern continues across the
region
and right here in our community
many other top names made the list
including steve nguyen david copperfield
dana white phil ruffin and floyd
mayweather we have a look at the list of
the highest residential and commercial
water users in 2021 on our website eight
newsnow dot com